on the eve of 9 11 the biden
administration getting blasted for
working in tandem with the taliban the
same terror group that 20 years ago gave
safe harbor to al-qaeda the white house
even praising them as the professional
and business-like while 100 americans
are still stuck in afghanistan meanwhile
while white house press secretary jensen
saying today this about accountability
i'm curious if there have been any
offers of resignation from anyone in the
chain of command or
any anyone involved in the decisions
with the uh evacuation no
um so the president still has confidence
in those
yes
so
dana we are seeing this break between
generals leadership in the pentagon and
veterans of the afghanistan war in the
past couple of weeks as people try to
process how this happened to end this
way well it's interesting also just that
if if somebody has
something of yours that is of value and
you need to get it back but they hold
all the cards you're going to have to be
nice to them
until you get it back and
it could be that one of the reasons they
have to use words like businesslike and
is because
they want to make sure that they can get
the americans or green card holders or
the people who helped us in the war out
which is probably obviously not
happening you've seen some of the
pictures today we know what the taliban
is doing i've actually also in touch as
i know a lot of you are with some of
these groups private groups former
veterans and and others that are trying
to get people out and the taliban is
hunting them and and they know that and
so it's like they're one step ahead of
the taliban to try to get this done but
they also are holding their fire because
they need the cooperation of the state
department in order to help them now
this you pay a price for not having
anybody on the ground it's one of the
things that they keep saying at the um
state department and at the white house
is that well we don't have anyone on the
ground so we're trying our best and i
just think
is such a debacle i cannot believe that
that were that has happened and um you
know i was just you know we on newsroom
we had the interview with the
interpreter carl
and we keep track of his progress i mean
he is safe but
there's just very little that can be
done outside of these outside groups
yeah so jesse if you look at a 911
tomorrow in the situation that the
united states is in with very little
leverage if any over the taliban
you have people looking back on the past
20 years looking back at the actions of
the obama administration the fact that
some of the people they swapped for beau
bergdahl
are now back in charge we were told by
the by administration that they would
not make it back to the battlefield
let's take a look at what jens hockey
said about it in 2015 and get you to
react
was it worth it absolutely we have a
commitment to our men and women serving
oversea or serving in our military
defending our national security every
day that we're going to do everything to
bring them home if we can and that's
what we did in this case
jesse look at the lengths that we went
to to bring back a deserter
we did not go to those same lengths to
bring back
allies americans stranded americans and
it cost us lives marines are dead
because of it
tomorrow 9 11 the 20th anniversary was
supposed to be a major deal for the
biden presidency if you think about his
running mate launch that strike to kill
osama bin laden joe biden was supposed
to come in tomorrow and close the
chapter in an iconic way on america's
longest war
and he's not going to do that he's not
even going to speak tomorrow katie
because what is he supposed to say he
blew it so badly stranding americans we
lost people we shouldn't have lost we
armed the enemy and so now he's just
going to go through ceremonies what
would he say anyway katie would it be
well received
by the crowd i don't think so could he
come up with the right words live in the
moment to convey what he thought about
it i don't think he'd be able to pull it
off someone said he's going to keep his
mouth shut the commander-in-chief after
we ended 20 years of war so when you
hear about this heaping praise on the
taliban i get it dana's right it's a
delicate dance you have hostages there
so you got to play nice but it leaves a
disgusting taste in the mouth of
everybody that hears it because
the taliban
put bullets through gi's chests
shot limbs off of americans i have
pictures on my phone
afghan allies right now
whips on their back brutality like you
wouldn't believe so the reason we're
doing this is strategic but we're here
because biden's dumb decisions
he got us into this situation where we
have to heat praise and he'll have to
own that for the rest of you yeah
this is a you know people are trying to
act like in the administration that this
just happened that you know there was no
way to really plan for this but at the
same time we planned for every single
contingency but jesse's right there
everything that has happened with the
last month with afghanistan
was a result of decisions that were made
either by the administration recently or
in in years past and it's not just about
the 20th anniversary of 9 11 tomorrow
where as americans we should be
remembering what happened that day the
taliban is expected to announce their
government they are back in charge
they're going to embarrass us on 9 11
and yet they're saying oh they're very
business-like and we can work with them
i think it was a bizarre idea to want
peace by 9 11 and to work so hard to
bring it about so that
instead of grieving over the 20 years
and the the event itself the trauma that
scarred so many people we're talking
about the taliban whether or not they're
going to keep their deal and we're you
know we're totally totally distracted a
couple of quick points number one there
was a second airplane out of afghanistan
today another flight they offered uh 40
odd american seats on that plane 19
accepted so the taliban
uh
think back to the 18 months when no gis
were killed in afghanistan
everyone thought that it was because we
held belgram and we could hold
background with 2500 people and why give
up it wasn't because of that it was
because the taliban wanted desperately
to succeed in the negotiation so they
played by their rule they negotiated
with president trump they negotiated
with president biden they they kept as
the flight indicates they are keeping
their
they are despicable low down and dirty
and i hate to have to continually uh
convince people how much i hate them but
the fact of the matter is they are
abiding by their deal i hate what they
do i hate the excesses i hate their
brutality their cruelty and all the rest
of it but the fact of the matter is they
are
playing by the rules that our negotiator
and their negotiators so tyrus speaking
of playing by the rules i have a feeling
we're going to learn about maybe some
pallets of cash or some recognition
promises here in the next six months
about what's really being promised this
is the simple story of the frog and the
scorpion this is the the woke
administration they defunded the police
they dealt the same way they defunded
our military they made deals they gave
them all the awards before they actually
did the work and now we're surprised and
they come up with wonderful things like
can you believe there's women not in
their government
that's our administration right
scorpion and the frog enough said
enough wisdom with tyrus